les initiatives des collectivités
territoriales en matière de santé donc
c'est un peu dire les journalistes un
marronnier depuis quelques temps c'est
un sujet récurrent qui préoccupe les
élus et qui sans aucun doute préoccupe
l'état également et disons que depuis
plusieurs années on assiste à deux
mouvements en matière de santé une sorte
de territorialisation un peu sous forme
de déconcentration avec la création des
agences régionales de santé mais on
pourra s'interroger sur la
déconcentration réel à l'aune de la
crise sanitaire et puis l'engagement
croissant des collectivités je pense
particulièrement aux communes et aux
départements
un engagement croissant d'interventions
dans ce champ de compétence non par
caprice mais par exigences parfois par
besoin parce que les territoires se sont
parfois vider d'un certain nombre de
services de santé que j'appellerais de
proximité mais aussi de services de
santé on va dire plus qui ne relèvent
pas de l'aune d'un territoire au
comunale je veux parler des hôpitaux et
notamment des spécialistes
alors on retrouve sans doute cette
tension dans les récentes annonces du
premier ministre après le ségur de la
santé puisque l'état a lancé à débloquer
des sommes très importantes de 9
milliards pour permettre au territoire
de lancer des projets locaux donc on
voit bien qu'on parle de territoire on
parle de projets mais avec en quelque
sorte un ensemblier si je cuisine un
chef d'orchestre
que serait la rs alors on a vu aussi on
a eu un éclairage nouveau et que le
sujet que nous abordons si c'est un
sujet
qui structurait il a aussi donné lieu à
des lectures un peu différente et la
crise sanitaire où on a vu l'enjeu d'un
on va dire d'un service de santé à la
population de proximité réactif et
l'engagement souvent des collectivités
est d'ailleurs monsieur renaud dit que
je salue vous avez vous avez repris la
phrase du président du sénat qui a dit
que la crise sanitaire avait vraiment
montrer la réactivité et l'agilité des
collectivités territoriales face à un
état qui était défaillant et moi je
culpabilise par l'état en quelque sorte
devant l'urgence mais sans doute
l'impuissance d'un état très lointain
très ankylosé à être un acteur très
opérationnelle en période de d'urgence
donc le sénat a avancé un certain nombre
de propositions pour consolider les
compétences des collectivités au sein
des 50 propositions qui ont été
présentées au président de la république
pour le plein exercice des libertés
locales et un certain nombre de rapports
ont été faits par nos collègues dont le
président de la commission d'aménagement
durable qui doit d'aménagement du
territoire pardon qui doit nous nous
nous rejoindre par visio et donc nous
aujourd'hui nous engageons des travaux
pour prendre connaissance des
initiatives qui existent de celles qui
sont possibles des blocages qui pourrait
être levé et non seulement pour
peut-être avoir ensuite des
préconisations législatives relatives à
la compétence au champ d'intervention
des collectivités en matière de santé
mais aussi pour aider d'aider des élus
dans une conduite de projets efficients
je pense que chacun de nous connaît dans
son territoire des élus extrêmement
engagés qui ont parfois construit des
maisons de santé où nous avons les murs
les ordinateurs les canapés mai
nous n'avons ni patients ni médecin
parce que ce projet a été engagé avec
beaucoup de sérieux par des élus mais
que ça n'a pas été un projet on va dire
partenariale et un projet de territoire
donc je veux saluer alors monsieur
valletoux doit nous rejoindre rappelle
que monsieur valletoux et président de
la fédération hospitalière de france il
est aussi maire de de fontainebleau
madame baisse je vous salue
vous êtes co présidente de la commission
santé de l'association des maires de
france et frédéric chéreau qui était si
à côté vous et co président à la
commission
dans cette même commission et puis je
salue monsieur renaudie qui nous
apportera un éclairage qui un éclairage
juridique vous êtes professeur de droit
public à l'université de paris 1 il vous
êtes auteur d'un récent article
extrêmement inspirant collectivités
territoriales et compétences en matière
de santé publique
sortir de l'ambiguïté point
d'interrogation
donc pour conclure mon introduction on
peut avoir
troisième question et mes collègues
compléteront naturellement avec des
questions qui seront extrêmement précise
et fort pertinente d'abord une question
importante c'est que pas faire
juridiquement les collectivités en
matière de santé aujourd'hui est ce
qu'il y a des verrous qui apparaissent
d'une manière extrêmement précise
aujourd'hui qu'il conviendrait de faire
sauter pour une meilleure efficacité de
l'action publique chez nous c'est notre
sujet l'efficacité de l'action publique
au dernier kilomètre si je puis dire
qu'elles sont des initiatives existantes
et sans doute la mf pourra nous en parle
et qui paraissent intéressantes et
quelles perspectives de développement
peut-on envisager et avant de vous
donner la parole j'ai une proposition à
soumettre à nos à nos collègues donc
comme nous avions annoncé cette mission
nous avions pressenti deux collègues
phil est mouillée qui est ici qu et
sénateurs des 2ème et qui monde
commission des affaires sociales et
patricia sheen âgé qui est le ici aussi
en vision et que je salue pour mener nos
travaux parce que nous suit aussi qu'il
y ait un lien très étroit avec la
commission des affaires sociales de
façon à ce que ce travail soit le plus
fructueux possible qu'ils enrichissent
l'ensemble des structures du sénat donc
mes chers collègues
y at il eu quelques avis ou quelques
commentaires sur ces propositions
donc je mets à votre approbation qui ne
dit mot consent bien vous soyez masqué
vous n'êtes pas censurer donc je
considère que les choses sont faites
voilà donc merci encore une fois nos
collègues des affaires sociales et de
l'aménagement du territoire et je
rappelle qu'à une captation vidéo qui
retransmise en direct dont merci
beaucoup je passe à part le petit tout
de suite à vous monsieur renaudie pour
que nous nous situions ce cadre
juridique et les interrogations qui sont
les vôtres je vous remercie
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente mesdames messieurs merci pour
cette invitation à participer à cette
table ronde 2 sur un sujet en effet vous
l'avez rappelé tout à la fois
d'actualité sur lequel il ya beaucoup à
dire
les relations entre les collectivités
territoriales est là et la santé mais me
semble marquée par une double ambiguïté
la première ambiguïté c'est que la
politique de santé publique aujourd'hui
et territorialisée c'est le mot qui est
utilisé par le code de la santé publique
nous qui a été introduit par la loi
touraine de 2016 territorialisée
c'est-à-dire au fonds adapté aux besoins
de santé d'un territoire donné
pourquoi cette territorialisation de la
santé deux motifs peuvent être avancées
le premier motif il tient à l'inégalité
dans l'accès aux soins
lesquels sont apparus de manière criante
à l'occasion de la crise sanitaire
de multiples facteurs démographiques
topographiques économiques sont à
l'origine de situations contrastées avec
d'un côté des zones particulièrement
bien doté en personnel et en moyens
sanitaires et de l'autre ceux que l'on
appelle parfois des déserts médicaux
il est donc important de corriger ces
inégalités territoriales par des outils
locaux
la seconde raison elle est d'un tout
autre ordre
elle tient aux différences
épidémiologique qui sont susceptibles
d'exister selon les territoires
comme le montre régulièrement les études
menées sur le sujet il y a des
différences qui sont susceptibles de
porter selon les territoires
là sur le taux de mortalité là sur la
prévalence de certaines maladies
cela conduit à considérer que le lieu de
résidence est un déterminant sociales de
la santé et justifie donc une approche
sanitaire différenciée selon les
territoires c'est vrai en période
normale
et naturellement c'est vrai également en
période de crise sanitaire
dès lors qu une territorialisation de la
santé et mise en oeuvre on pourrait
penser que les collectivités
territoriales ont constitué les
principaux acteurs il n'en est rien il
n'en est rien les territoires concernés
par ce mouvement ne sont pas ceux des
collectivités du même nom mais ce sont
les lieux qui ont été choisis par les
organes centraux de l'état pour
concevoir et pour appliquer la politique
sanitaire
autrement dit la territorialisation de
la santé est opérée non pas dans le
cadre de la décentralisation et dans
celui de la déconcentration au delà de
cette première ambiguïté il en est une
seconde qui mérite d'être d'être relevé
elle tient à ce qu en apparence les
choses sont simples la santé publique l
affaire exclusif de l'état
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu affirme sans
ambages le code de la santé publique la
politique de santé relève de la
responsabilité de l'état point
qu'est ce qui justifie cette compétence
exclusive
de l'état n'y deux motifs là encore
premier motif c'est un motif d'ordre
historique
l'évolution du secteur sanitaire est
marquée par une appropriation progressif
par l'état des questions sanitaires
notamment
je ne peux pas manqué de le relever à la
suite d'épisodes épidémiques à chaque
fois qu'il ya eu une épidémie l'état
s'est approprié un petit peu plus à la
suite de celle ci de compétences en
matière sanitaire
le second motif c'est un motif d'ordre
juridique il est important c'est le
principe d'égalité non pas comme on le
dit parfois principe d'égalité devant la
loi
non c'est l'alinéa 11 du préambule de la
constitution de 1946 selon lequel la
nation garantit à tous
la protection de la santé voilà le
fondement juridique de la compétence de
de l'état et c'est sur ce fondement
constitutionnel qu'il revient à l'état
d'assurer sur l'ensemble du territoire
national d'une part l'égal accès aux
soins et d'autre part l'égalité dans la
distribution des soins pour autant et on
le sait est votre introduction l'a
rappelé les choses sont plus complexes
en pratique si on se donne la peine de
voir derrière les les apparences on ne
peut que constater que les collectivités
territoriales et la crise du coronavirus
la confirmer ou révéler ne sont pas
totalement exclu c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire du champ sanitaire
prenons chacun des échelons
commençons d'abord par les communes
elles sont certainement les
collectivités dont le rôle est le plus
important en matière de santé ça tient à
des considérations historiques 1
rappelons que par exemple sous la
période révolutionnaire c'était bien
elle à qui l'on avait confié les
questions sanitaires et puis bien sûr
leur statut d'échelon de proximité les
conduit à exercer des pouvoirs en la
matière alors je pourrais en citer
beaucoup sans doute seront évoqués il ya
quelques instants j'en prend 2,2
compétences liées à la santé une
classique celle de police au titre de
ses pouvoirs de police administrative
générale
mr peut prendre toutes mesures pour
assurer la salubrité publique et il lui
appartient de prévenir par des
précautions convenable et de faire
cesser par la distribution de secours
nécessaires les accidents les fléaux
calamiteux les maladies épidémiques ou
contagieuse
c'est ce qui figure à l'article l 22 12
2 du code général des collectivités
cependant et il faut le rappeler est là
encore la crise sanitaire l'a montré
cette compétence de police du maire est
limitée par un certain nombre de police
administrative spéciale détenu par les
autorités étatiques deuxième compétence
le service communal d'hygiène et de
santé qui est placé sous l'autorité du
maire ou du président de le pci et qui
exercent des attributions en matière
d'hygiène de l'alimentation de l'habitat
s'agissant des départements il constitué
on le sait bien sûr l'échelon essentiel
du dispositif relatif à l'action sociale
et médico sociale
c'est à ce titre que le départements
exercent des compétences susceptibles
d'intéresser la santé deux exemples là
encore d'un côté le service de
protection maternelle et infantile dont
le conseil départemental et est
responsable et assure le financement de
l'autre bien sûr on en a beaucoup parlé
à l'occasion de la crise la compétence
du président du conseil départemental
pour autoriser la création de certains
établissements sociaux et médico-sociaux
et pour gérer certains établissements
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes les épate
ça sent des régions elle constitue une
ambiguïté dans l'ambiguïté alors même
que l'échelon régional a été promu comme
le cadre principal de l'action sanitaire
de l'état avec les ars
le conseil régional lui dispose en
matière sanitaire de compétences
relativement modeste qui s'articule au
fond autour de deux pôles le premier
pôle c'est la prévention sanitaire le
conseil régional peut définir des
objectifs particuliers en matière de
santé élaboré des programmes de
prévention de certaines maladies et
d'information sur celle ci est le
deuxième pôle concerne la formation
les professionnels de santé vous
connaissez naturellement le lien entre
la formation et le conseil régional
il est remarquable que s'agissant du
champ sanitaire le conseil régional et
la charge du fonctionnement et de
l'équipement d'un certain nombre
d'écoles ou d'instituts par exemple ceux
qui forment les sages femmes ou les
préparateurs en pharmacie hospitalière
lorsqu'ils sont publiques
au-delà des compétences propres de
chacun de ces trois échelons
je voudrais insister sur une compétence
dévolue à tous et gestion est aussi
également aux établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale et qui est
peut-être un peu négligé même si on l'a
évoqué à propos des maisons de santé
c'est la possibilité qu'elle ait laissé
par le code général des collectivités à
l'ensemble des échelons de pouvoir
attribuer des aides destinées à
favoriser l'installation ou le maintien
de professionnels de santé dans dans
certaines zones
une fois rappeler cette double ambiguïté
je crois nécessaire d'en sortir
comment sur la forme il convient de
réfléchir en même temps et sans jeu de
mots aux dimensions décentralisées et
déconcentrées de la politique de santé
publique
ce serait une première jusqu alors on a
toujours réfléchi soit d'un côté soit de
l'autre jamais ensemble
sur le fond je voudrais pour conclure
souligné trois éléments
d'abord je crois que d'une manière ou
d'une autre il convient que le
législateur précise que la santé n'est
pas une compétence exclusive de l'état
et précise qui fait quoi précise qu'il y
a en la matière une gouvernance une
coproduction et précise quel est le rôle
de chacun et comment ces actions sont
susceptibles d'être complémentaire pour
être efficiente
ensuite il convient là encore d'une
manière ou d'une autre organisme en ou
fonctionnellement de mieux associer les
collectivités territoriales à l'action
conduite par les par les airs
enfin je voudrais évoquer un échelon
peut-être oublié c'est peut-être parce
que chez philippe daly en face de moi
mais je voudrais dire un mot des
métropoles
car s'il est bien un échelon s'il est
bien un échelon qui est très oublié
c'est celui des métropoles ce ça n'est
pas normal dès lors qu'elles sont elles
sont jeunes mais enfin je trouve que
dans le domaine sanitaire
la crise a révélé qu'elle était
susceptible d'être un échelon pertinent
la vue s'agissant de mesures comme le
confinement ou les vaccinations
j'ajoute à cela qu'en période normale
des initiatives tenant à la lutte contre
les nuisances sonores ou bien encore à
la qualité de l'air montre le lien très
important entre santé et environnement
et voilà un duo qui mériterait également
d'être travaillée merci madame la
présidente
merci beaucoup professeur voilà un peu
de teasing et de points d'interrogation
nous aimons au sénat donc je vais passer
la parole à madame monsieur giraud le
cheval tous été annoncé que trente
minutes de retard
ensuite je passerai la parole à nos deux
rapporteurs que je félicite voilà pour
cette nouvelle fonction et n'hésitez pas
à souhaiter à vous manifester si vous
souhaitez intervenir
merci madame est sûr monsieur chéreau je
vous laisse vous ordonnez et si je puis
dire on va se partager le temps merci
madame la présidente de nous avoir
associé à vos à vos travaux qui sont
très importants aujourd'hui savoir
associer la mf effectivement nous co
président avec frédéric chéreau mon
collègue la commission santé de
de l'association des maires de france et
nous sommes à la base mais rossi je suis
maire des herbiers commune de 16 mille
cinq cents habitants en vendée proches
de chez mon voisin des deux sèvres et
présidente de la communauté de communes
du pays des herbiers dont convient
effectivement au quotidien tous ces
problèmes de santé je rejoins tout à
fait ce qu'a dit le professeur renaudie
sur les difficultés que nous avons sur
le terrain et je crois qu'effectivement
l'échelon local est un bon échelon pour
tout ce qui touche à la santé et on le
voit encore plus aujourd'hui avec la
crise sanitaire ou les mères
applique ce qui est décidé par par le
gouvernement toujours un peu dans
l'urgence
toujours un peu dans une certaine aussi
cacophonie quand je dis dans l'urgence
c'est souvent on reçoit des circulaires
à 18 heures le vendredi soir pour une
application dans les écoles lundi matin
mais on le fait parce que je pense que
les maires sont des bons soldats mais on
se préoccupe pas en fait personne se
préoccupe de la difficulté que nous
avons à mettre tout ça sur le terrain on
a si je prends l'exemple de la cristiani
terre on a connu le problème des masques
on a connu le problème des tests et
maintenant on connaît le problème des
vaccins ma commune et comme beaucoup
d'autres communes un centre de
vaccination ce qui n'est pas simple et
en fait le maire étant au bout de la
chaîne aussi pour tous les problèmes de
santé et on doit et on dit souvent qu'on
est en a apporté dans le late c'est à
dire qu'on doit répondre à nos
concitoyens qui connaissent leur mère
avant tout et donc il faut qu'on soit
toujours dans cette proximité
je pense que l'échelon local est un
excellent échelons pour la santé pour
plus de proximité parce que nous
connaissons nos territoires pour plus de
réactivité
parce que là on voit les lourdeurs
administratives pour plus aussi de bon
sens parce que quelquefois des textes
législatifs arrive
et tout le monde est un peu traités de
la même façon c'est-à-dire l'échelon
alors je prends l'exemple ça n'a rien à
voir avec la santé mais l'échelon de la
fermeture des femmes e commerce non
essentiels à ça n'a rien à voir avec la
santé mais c'est un exemple que l'on
pourrait aussi donner dans la santé
faire que l'on considère que les belles
très bon mais l'avenue des champs
elysées et traités de la même façon ou
du moins la petite rue commerçante de ma
commune est traité de la même façon que
les champs elysées bon ben je referme je
caricature mais à peine c'est à dire que
voilà ça manque un petit peu de bon sens
dont proximité réactivité bon sens et
puis innovation je pense que les maires
ou les présidents de métropole est prise
en intercommunalité avec leurs équipes
sont tout à fait capables
de d'innover et notamment dans le
domaine de la santé parce que nous
savons ce qui est bon pour nos
territoires donc ce que
nous demandons ce que moi je demande en
tant que maire mais je pense que c'est
partagé par mon collègue frédéric
chéreau c'est beaucoup plus de liberté
en fait il faut qu'on nous sommes
responsables nous sommes des élus
responsables
nous savons ce qui est bon pour nos
territoires et je pense que nous
manquons aujourd'hui de liberté
notamment dans le domaine de la santé
vous avez soulevé aussi le problème des
ars on pourra peut-être en reparler tout
à l'heure c'est un vrai problème
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que moi j'ai le
sentiment pour les côtoyer assez souvent
comme tous les élus que nous sommes
écoutez mais nous sommes pas entendus
c'est à dire que on parle on propose
ont quelquefois on
on est un peu en colère on le voit avec
les problèmes de vaccinations
mais rien rien ne change rien ne change
et moi je souhaiterais que le préfet
dans les départements est beaucoup plus
de l'attitude vis-à-vis de la rs c'est à
dire qu'il soit le patron en fait
deux dans le département en matière de
santé puisque la rs aujourd'hui le
couple préférait chez moi en tous les
cas ne fonctionne pas ne fonctionne pas
bien
voilà ce que je vais vous dire merci
merci beaucoup madame et je profite de
votre présence pour vous dire enfin
titre personnel mais je pense que chacun
d'entre nous il a exprimé le sénat l'a
exprimé la gratitude que nous devons
avoir vis-à-vis des des maires et des
élites en l'occurrence et illizi
essentielle
pendant la crise sanitaire puisque on a
vu comment un présent la république peut
dire je veux que les écoles ouvrent et
ce sont les élus locaux qui peuvent le
faire donc ce que l'on vous doit donc
merci à vous monsieur frédéric géraud
président même le président du d'abord
commencé par me joindre au bout
remerciements de ma collègue véronique
besse à votre égard merci de votre
invitation merci de l'attention que vous
portez à ce sujet de la santé et surtout
la position des élus locaux
parce que nous vivons au quotidien merci
aussi parole l'occasion que vous nous
offrez de faire un petit tour à paris où
ce qui est toujours agréable quand on
est un peu cloîtré dans son territoire
même si on adore nos territoires voilà
nous avait un peu déconfit nez et ça
n'est pas le moindre attrait de cette
journée vous m'avez aussi offert la
possibilité de rencontrer de visu ma
collègue mais en hiver et je vous en
remercie
au delà du clin d'oeil madame la
présidente je ne ferai pas très long sur
le territoire d'où je viens dans la
mesure où nous représentons l'un et
l'autre l'ensemble des maires de la nf1
mots simplement pour vous dire quand
même que le territoire du douaisis est
un des territoires de france
métropolitaine avec les indicateurs de
santé les plus dégradés à la fois parce
que les déterminants de santé ils sont
dégradés pollution industrielle
urbanisme compliqué parfois faibles à
sens des espaces verts etc et également
parce qu'on y trouve des pathologies en
nombre est beaucoup plus importante que
dans le reste du territoire et une
mortalité de 30 pour cent plus
importantes à toutes les tranches d'âge
que la moyenne nationale
j'ai bu les paroles tout à l'heure du
professeur renaudie et je me retrouve
tout à fait dans ce qu'il a dit comme a
dit véronique besse il a été souligné
qu' évidemment la santé est une
compétence exclusive de l'état
mais quand bien même nous ne
souhaiterions pas nous y intéresser en
réalité la santé la question de la santé
vient à nous en permanence
j'allais dire au début j'avais commencé
à écrire que la santé le troisième sujet
en général pour lequel vient nous voir
après le logement et l'emploi ou
l'emploi et le logement en avant que
vous voulez en réalité c'est souvent en
même temps ça mais je salue sa nouvelle
tant que j'ai le plaisir de boire pour
deux fois en deux jours
voilà je disais que la santé le
troisième sujet pour lequel on vient
voir son maire en général après l'emploi
et le logement et essais souvent même
lié au sujet de l'emploi ou du logement
l'emploi pour les problèmes de handicap
le logement parce qu'on vient nous dire
il faut une maison moi je peux plus
monter un escalier je suis essoufflée
j'ai une insuffisance cardiaque est ce
que je dois faire déménager mois les
habitants viennent nous voir parce
qu'ils n'ont plus de médecins traitants
les habitants nous nous rencontrons
aussi c'est souvent la nuit souvent le
week-end des problèmes de santé mentale
dans nos territoires nos ccas évidemment
quand on défait la pelote de toutes les
problématiques d'une personne pour
essayer de l'aider à se réinsérer la
santé est toujours un des déterminants
et un des problèmes non traités dans nos
écoles de rencontre les questions du
handicap d'allergies et c est en réalité
le seul endroit où les élus locaux sont
de droit dans tous les territoires
invités à participer à des questions de
santé ce sont uniquement les conseils de
surveillance des hôpitaux qui ne sont
d'ailleurs plus des conseils
d'administration mais des conseils bien
de surveillance voilà et au delà dans lé
groupement hospitalier de territoire
alors je vais pas rentrer dans le détail
sur les contenants hospitalier
territoires sur lesquels personnellement
j'ai peut-être quelques questionnements
je pense que en termes de zonage c'est
pas forcément très confortable et pas
toujours pertinents et c'est ce sont des
outils qui sont exclusivement
hospitalier est exclusivement hôpital
public mais je vais laisser ce sujet la
côte est nous militons et véronique
besse l'adie pour une approche
territoriale et globale systémique de la
santé
où les élus puissent évidemment
s'intéresser à la santé au sens strict
nous finançons des maisons de santé
nous finançons l'aide à l'installation
de professionnels de santé nous pouvons
travailler aussi sur le lien ville
hôpital et ça c'est important c'est
quelque chose que j'ai eu l'occasion de
mettre en place dans le douaisis c'est
tout bête c'est tout bête mais les
médecins hospitaliers et les médecins de
ville s'apprécie mais se méfie parfois
les uns des autres ce sont deux mondes
qui ne savent pas forcément toujours si
bien que ça travailler ensemble en tout
cas quand le catalyseur élus et là ça
marche beaucoup mieux
et puis nous voulons une approche
systémique de la santé c'est aussi
s'intéresser à tous le halo qui est
autour de ce choeur strictement
sanitaires c'est à dire tout ce qui est
le socio sanitaire le lien avec les
services locaux du département le
professeur renaudie en a parlé avec nos
ateliers santé ville avec nos
associations de prévention mais j'ai une
association sur la santé du coeur une
association pour le sport des personnes
malades et c'est là-dessus d'ailleurs
sur cette approche-là l'importance des
contrats locaux de santé est à souligner
c'est un outil qui n'est pas encore
généralisé en france il ya un autre sens
devraient l'être et puis ya tout ce qui
est au delà les déterminants de santé au
sens large sur lesquels aussi les
collectivités sont aux premières loges
l'alimentation dans les écoles les
espaces verts le sport la qualité du
logement l'air le bruit le professeur
renaudie en a parlé avec justement une
une approche très différente d'un
territoire à l'autre et où dont il est
absolument essentiel que ya un regard
locales à travers ce que nos scott nos
deux pays et nos communes peuvent
construire et cette approche des
déterminants de santé et majeur parce
qu'en réalité aujourd'hui et nous le
constatons au quotidien les principales
pathologies a reconnu que nous
rencontrons peut-être pas là en ce
moment où c'est un virus qui nous pose
problème et en lités sont des
pathologies de sociétés des pathologies
de mode de vie des pathologies
environnementales
c'est le diabète c'est d'insuffisance
cardiaque ce sont ces deux visites et
c'est toute l'époque pathologies liées
au vieillissement
donc ce ne sont pas des pathologies qui
se traite avec un samu ce sont des
pathologies qui se traite sur l'acompte
la compréhension du mode de vie de la
personne et son accompagnement au long
cours
c'est pour ça que nous avons le
sentiment que le modèle pré nationale
centralisée hospital au centre et alors
qui a eu son heure de gloire et qui a
été un moment donné nécessaire c'est
tout ce qu'a construit debré à partir de
58 ce modèle là aujourd'hui et à trouver
peut-être son sa limite et doit trouver
un second souffle
il a même aujourd'hui des billets moi je
le constate en tant que président de
conseil de surveillance un modèle très
centrée sur l'hôpital et sur les
urgences
ça coûte cher et des gens qui se
retrouvent aux urgences qui ne devraient
pas y être
les hôpitaux râle que leur urgence en
surchargé mais les urgences et le
principal apporteur d'affaires de
l'hôpital et comme on est arrivé à
l'activité avoir de l'activité c'est
bien et quand temps en temps on peut
aussi faire monter des urgences des gens
dans les étages même si c'est pas
strictement nécessaires et de préférence
les faire revenir après même si c'est
pas strictement nécessaires
c'est toujours de l'activité dont vous
avez des billets comme ça je n'accuse
pas les individus mais c'est le système
qui les génère est liée à ce système 13
hospital au centre et le système drs qui
elles aussi sont très centrée sur
l'hôpital est un petit peu à bout de
souffle
ce que nous défendons nous c'est un
modèle territoriale fondée sur la
prévention le repérage l'accompagnement
est un modèle je le souligne parce que
parfois les élus fallait peut être un
peu accusé on ne dit pas mais d'être
ceux qui veulent toujours plus de sous
qui réclame des moyens qui n'en ont
jamais assez et qui eux mêmes sont
peut-être un peu dépensiers voilà en
réalité un modèle de ce type qui empêche
les gens d'être malade
l'idée c'est plutôt moins de de soigner
dans l'urgence les pathologies quand
elles apparaissent que d'empêcher les
gens d'être malade de repérer à l'avance
ce modèle là ne coûte pas plus cher et
je vous parlerai un petit peu plus si
vous le souhaitez d'une expérience que
nous menons dans le douaisis mais je
sais que c'est également le cas dans les
deux sèvres et manable président un peu
plus loin chez vous en bretagne dans la
cornouaille c'est la responsabilité
populationnelle aujourd'hui des outils
comme les big data permettent de
travailler de manière beaucoup plus fine
sur le suivi des maladies que sont
notamment d'insuffisance cardiaque et le
diabète
repérez largement à l'avance proposer un
accompagnement via les médecins
traitants et permettre aux gens de vivre
avec leur maladie en les stabilisant moi
je j'ai été long je n'irai pas beaucoup
plus loin
encore une fois merci de votre attention
à ce sujet nous sommes à votre
disposition
merci monsieur coprésidents donc
effectivement je pense que on va garder
le maximum de temps pour le débat merci
beaucoup et vous savez qu'ici vous êtes
dans un camp d'été doit et nous nous
sommes convaincus persuadé que les élus
locaux sont des inventeurs de ce méchant
et qui sont parfois des chefs
d'orchestre dans tout un champ on va
dire de compétences ou de services aux
habitants et notamment tour de la santé
encore une fois plaidé le maire il est
l'incarnation de la république de
l'égalité de droits et de liberté
jusqu'au dernier kilomètre et lui doit
inventer les choses monsieur le
président valletoux vraiment je vous
remercie très chaleureusement d'être
connaître l'âge c'est que voilà votre
temps est aussi très précieux
donc nous avons démarré suite à leur
table ronde donc juste pour situer on va
dire le champ de notre réflexion donc la
délégation aux collectivités
territoriales et à la ddt et à la
décentralisation est une structure qui
une structure on va dire de réflexion de
prospection d' analyse de diagnostic qui
en tout cas s'intéresse à l'efficacité
de l'action publique dans tous les
champs de dd des compétences y compris
de celles qui sont pas donnés et qui
devrait l'être et nous nous sommes en
amont du travail des commissions qui
sont des commissions on va dire
spécialisés et thématiques et donc nous
pouvons par ce regard que nous avons qui
vraiment le regard des élus locaux nous
pouvons nourrir des travaux de de nos
deux de nos collègues et des commissions
y contribuer en association très
étroites et les collègues en
l'occurrence avec de la commission des
affaires sociales
un procédé à des avancées législatives
quand elles sont nécessaires donc nous
notre regard c'est celui des bonnes
pratiques des choses qu'il faudrait sans
doute déverrouiller alors chacun l'a dit
il y a un regard particulier ou un
éclairage particulier qui lie à la crise
sanitaire mais nous savons qu'au delà de
la crise sanitaire
il ya une question récurrente qui est
largement aussi éclairé par ces crises
sanitaires donc je ne serai pas plus
longue professeur sachant que vous avez
une
alors les mains sont des couteaux
suisses jeudi parce qu'on voit bien que
les interpelle surtout mais vous vous
avez vraiment une double compétence que
je salue puisque vous êtes à la fois un
homme du sérail si je puis dire enfin du
sérail santé et du sérail élu local donc
voilà votre repérage sera aussi
extrêmement intéressant merci beaucoup
président président suis vraiment confus
de 2,2 de mon retard
mais qui est plus sied aux
embouteillages de l'ile-de-france que
aux contraintes de la crise sanitaire du
moment mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs donc merci de m'accueillir à
ses talons je pense que vous faites bien
de vous interroger sur effectivement la
place des collectivités locales et des
territoires dans le devenir du système
de santé parce que je pense que si la
crise va nous révéler quelques évidences
la première c'est que les français
tiennent éminemment à leur système de
santé
la deuxième évidence c'est que ce
système de santé et notamment phrase un
peu pro domo mais je le jeu j'y crois
profondément
l'hôpital a vraiment pour l'instant et
aucune raison que ça change jouer son
rôle de bouclier sanitaire des français
dans cette dans cette crise avec bien
sûr l'ensemble des cdd des
professionnels quel que soit leur statut
mais néanmoins l'hôpital a quand même
été veut dire au premier au premier en
première ligne de cette crise est la
troisième chose c'est que cette crise
est arrivée à un moment enfin sur un
système qui était déjà malade et qui
souffrait de nombreux dysfonctionnements
et qu' on ne fera pas l'économie et la
dent sortie de crise d'une d'abord d'un
retour d'expérience mais ensuite d'une
remise à plat certainement de ce système
de santé de manière à effectivement
pérenniser ce qui menaçait non pas
d'effondrement mais dans tous les cas ce
menaçait de difficultés c'est ce système
de santé traversé de nombreuses crises
je n'aborderai pas là bien sûr les
questions de financement je n'aborderai
pas là des questions même si on va on va
on va y venir un peu de gouvernance du
système est de ceux là
l'opacité la difficulté de ce
fonctionnement j'aborderai pas non plus
la montée en puissance d'un système qui
s'est beaucoup bureaucratisé ces
dernières années au détriment de
comment dire de la delà de la confiance
que l'on peut faire aux acteurs et
notamment aux acteurs de terrain mais en
tout cas la crise a aussi révélé et bien
qu'on ne pouvait pas faire sans les
collectivités locales et sans les élus
locaux
et ça on l'a vu dès la première vague et
on continue à le constater avec le
déploiement de la campagne de
vaccination
c'est une conviction profonde que je
portais mais qu'avec l'ensemble de ceux
qui s'impliquent dans la fédération
hospitalière de france dont je veux dire
qu'elle est tout autant une association
d'élus que d'hospitalité puisque un
tiers du conseil d'administration de la
fédération spyder de france est composée
d'élus un tiers de directeurs d'hôpitaux
et un tiers de médecins hospitaliers
donc il ya vraiment toutes les
composantes de ce qu'ils font la santé
publique dans les territoires qui
participent à cette fédération et qui la
font vivre
donc la conviction profonde de de tous
c'était bien que l'avenir de la 6ème de
santé passer par une réforme qui je
valorise une approche par les indh a
parlé des territoires
quand on regarde les grands champs de
l'action publique il est frappant de
voir que dans les grandes politiques
régaliennes
il ya eu des moments de modernisation
des structures publiques
je pense à tout ce qui concernait
l'économie et des finances le système du
trésor enfin tout ce que bercy a fait
dans les années 90 on a vu d'autres
grandes chances d'avoir des réactions
publiques se moderniser et finalement le
seul qui paraît avoir échappé aux
réflexions sur la réforme de l'état
quelques qu'elle qui a été le nom des
politiques menées ça a été le ministère
de la santé est finalement derrière
toute la politique de santé de notre de
notre pays avec des structures qui se
sont complexifiées bureaucratisé je le
disais au fil du temps et qui finalement
ont aussi plutôt eu tendance à exclure
des acteurs locaux plus qu'elle ne les
associés aujourd'hui la france fait face
à un déficit de médecins c'est peut-être
son principal écueil où il n'ya pas de
génération spontanée médecin donc il va
falloir gérer encore pendant quelques
années la pénurie
et si on va pas vers un système qui
valorise les initiatives locales qui
fait baisser les barrières entre les
professionnels de santé quel que soit
leur statut public privé libéraux
spécialistes généralistes etc
si on va pas vers un système qui inclut
mieux les paramédicaux qui inclut mieux
les politiques de prévention on
ne sauvera pas un système de santé dont
je doute on rappelait que les français
et y tiennent d'eau que l'un des enjeux
c'est de décloisonner à des enjeux c'est
de favoriser effectivement la proche par
les territoires et finalement de laisser
imaginer les professionnels de santé en
lien avec les collectivités locales des
systèmes de prise en charge qui peuvent
être très différents d'un territoire à
l'autre
frédéric parler du douaisis tout à
l'heure les données de santé dans le
douaisis sont pas du tout les mêmes que
celles qui sont dans le sud
seine-et-marne chez moi à fontainebleau
et sont pas les mêmes que dans la nièvre
laisserons pas les voilà et à partir de
là ce qu'on attend d'un système de santé
quelle que soit la qualité des acteurs
leur qualité juridique c'est qu'ils
répondent aux besoins de santé des
français et que finalement ils
s'attaquent aux mots de ces deux des
populations qui l'ont à servir je
rappelle que le système de santé
financés par par l'assurance maladie
donc par la cotisation des français par
un système de solidarité nationale et
qu'à partir de là même ceux qui ont un
statut de libéral quelque part sont
aussi financé par de l'argent collectif
de l'argent de la solidarité et donc ils
doivent répondre au moins si ce n'est à
des missions de service public en tous
les cas à ddd à des missions dont il
porte aussi des missions d'intérêt
d'intérêt général et donc la
compréhension aussi dangereux qui ne
sont pas uniquement fin qui sont des
enjeux des enjeux publics pourquoi je
dis ça parce que dans dans l'est dans
l'étang dans les dents les dans les mois
et années à venir il va il va falloir
effectivement arrivé comme le décrivait
très bien frédéric pour pour ça pour sa
ville à faire travailler ensemble des
gens qui jusqu'à présent cohabitent plus
qu'il ne plus qu'il ne coopèrent
et l'expérience qu'il a eu la
gentillesse d'évoquer de responsabilité
populationnelle initiée par la
fédération hospitalière de france était
est une démonstration par la preuve la
preuve que nous essayons de faire
inspiré du canada et notamment du québec
qui a réorganisé son système de santé
autour de ce principe de la
responsabilité populationnelle vous
professionnels de santé au sens large
vous êtes sur un territoire qui a des
données de santé qui ont ces
caractéristiques
vous avez la responsabilité de la prise
en charge et vous avez la pensée la
responsabilité d'inventer des réponses à
ces enjeux de santé publique
quelles sont elles moi je suis l'état je
vous définit le l'objectif et après dans
la mise en oeuvre je vous laisse faire
par contre je suis l'état et donc je
serai aussi le vérificateur le garant et
en tous les cas je serai à la sortie
l'évaluateur de la pertinence et
l'efficacité des dispositifs cloud
proposé et là on voit déjà construit
dans un autre système qui ferait
beaucoup plus confiance aux acteurs du
territoire avec un état qui serait bien
repositionnés dans la définition des
grandes missions et les rangs objectifs
de santé publique
il est le garant jaillir des grands
équilibres en matière de santé publique
sera vis-à-vis de la nation
et puis d'un territoire qui se concentre
pas à pinailler à faire au dessus de la
tête des acteurs mais qui capable aussi
de les accompagner dans dans l'efficace
dans la dans la dans l'évaluation des
dispositifs mis en oeuvre puisqu'il en
est aussi le financeur global voilà et 7
ce schéma là on expérimente donc dans
autour de deux pathologies
l'insuffisance cardiaque était le
diabète dans cinq territoires qui ont
été cités le douaisis la région de
troyes la cornouaille la région de niort
et vesoul le territoire et le doubs
ça fait deux ans qu'on travaille on
laisse faire les acteurs locaux pour
inventer des réponses à ces deux
pathologies que j'évoquais et on pourra
faire la démonstration effectivement que
et bien la recherche en efficacité sur
ces deux pathologies allait passer par
des voies qui sont différentes selon les
territoires parce que les forces en
présence dans les territoires sont pas
les mêmes voilà je voulais juste à la
fois faire le lien avec ce que frédéric
disait si tu essaies tu cette démarche
parce que j'y crois profondément
il sert et démonstration par la preuve
que si on fait confiance aux plans
inventer des choses adaptés aux besoins
et et ça me paraît être un bon élément
de ce que pourrait être le rôle des
collectivités locales et j'en terminerai
par là demain parce que évidemment tout
ça ne fonctionne que si au milieu de
tous ces acteurs qui ont des intérêts
divergents parce que les systèmes de
financement sont pas les mêmes
parce que les intérêts agir d un des
autres sont pas les mêmes s'il n'y a pas
au milieu de tout ça les élus pour
finalement jouer le rôle dedans
d'entraînement mais aussi finalement de
chef d'orchestre de pacificateur parfois
croatie à des conflits de porter de
l'intérêt général de rap est
effectivement chacun porte une mission
qui peut être la dépasse et bien ça
c'est le rôle des élus si y'a pas les
élus qui s'y impliquent fortement ça ne
marchera pas donc c'est un exemple parmi
d'autres effectivement on pourrait
parler après dé la place des élus n'en
dans tel ou tel dispositif mais mais en
tous les cas là l'élu le g10 reportent
ça porte ses missions qui est qui et
première est essentiel d'être celui qui
fait avancer
oh non l'intérêt général les acteurs
d'un territoire
merci monsieur le président monsieur
mère je crois que vous donner une
définition assez remarquable de ce
qu'est une compétence régalienne
c'est à dire qu'il y à un état qui doit
garantir
un service qui doit garantir une équité
et ensuite il y à l'action de faire et
faire ça se fait sur les territoires
comme vous l'avez dit ça se fait
ensemble église élus locaux sont souvent
des dix ensemblier ils sont des chefs
d'orchestre des médiateurs en tout cas
c'est eux qui impulse et je salue ma
collègue élisabeth doineau qui est de
mayenne qui venait expliquer dans mon
département d'ille-et-vilaine des mères
qui voulait absolument avoir des maisons
de santé plein de médecins que ce
n'était pas à eux seuls qu'ils allaient
réussir la fermer comme vous dites de 7
ans s'en est donc votre double casquette
est intéressante
alors nous avons beaucoup de prises de
parole je vais d'abord passer la parole
à nos deux rapporteurs philippe bouyer
et patricia sillinger et ensuite laurent
burgoa philippe dallier nous aurons
ensuite trois demandes de parole on voit
le sujet est au coeur de nos
préoccupations sans doute il est au
coeur des préoccupations des français de
l'exigence de servir nos concitoyens
jusqu'au dernier kilomètre cher philippe
louis merci madame la présidente tout
d'abord en introduction permettez moi
monsieur le président de vous remercier
vous ils nos collègues de la désignation
de deux nous aura recharger avec pathé
sache nager de ceux de ce rapport avec
on voit bien un enjeu extrêmement
important pour le territoire et donc qui
mobilise beaucoup d'élus donc merci
beaucoup pour pour 7 pour 7 pour cette
mission nous avons cette table ronde est
l'occasion de lancer nos travaux donc
s'élever vous êtes les premiers à
débattre avec nos délégations est en
tout cas un grand merci pour vos apports
d'information vos retours d'expérience
et lorsque nous avons préparé un peu ses
travaux ont notamment cette future
mission
on nous avons décidé finalement d'abord
des choses par par deux aspects d'abord
a coûté très pragmatique et un peu
l'essence même du sénat ces terres nous
appuyer sur les expériences dont vous
avez déjà vous lister un certain nombre
d'initiatives mais je reste persuadé que
c'est en s'enrichissant des bonnes et
parfois des dépenses plus compliqué sur
des territoires portés par les
collectivités porté par les partenaires
de la santé
nous pourrons tirer un certain nombre
d'enseignements et peut-être apporter un
certain nombre de recommandations ou une
jambe de gier est de 2 2 2 2 voies à
porter pour essayer de relier un certain
nombre de bonnes idées de bonnes
pratiques ça c'est un point qui est pour
nous important et donc naturellement
s'appuyant sur les grandes associations
de collectivités pour avoir justement
j'irai des ddd des sujets et des
expériences à regarder et puis très
rapidement à se rendre compte que on
l'abordé telle heure avec le professeur
on va très vite arriver sur des débats
en matière de compétences en matière de
police du maire en matière de capacité à
faire de réglementation est très
rapidement forcément aussi le sujet de
la compétence ou ou des compétences
partagées sera un point essentiel parce
que l'expérimentation nous permet à
cette ombre de liberté mais la
généralisation nécessite forcément un
cadre réglementaire voilà donc ce sera à
peu près les deux approches sur lequel
nous allons regarder nos travaux et en
sachant que les jours et mois donc pour
lancer les questions revenir très
spécialement spécifiquement sur les
enjeux concernant les pôles la police du
maire avec peut-être quelques exemples
la compétence des communes en matière de
santé publique est marquée par un
paradoxe parce que à la faute du pouvoir
de police administrative générale le
maire est habilitée à prendre toutes
mesures pour assurer la salubrité
publique salubrité publique et donc on
se rend compte que cette compétence
générale se trouve limitée souvent par
les dispositions laissait-il selon
laquelle la politique de santé relève de
la responsabilité de l'état
voilà donc je vais avoir un peu votre
votre votre avis sur cette ambiguïté
entre les enjeux celui-ci publique
police du maire obligations du maire et
finalement la responsabilité de l'état
qui exercent pleinement cette compétence
c'est ce paradoxe a été illustrée
notamment au moment de la crise
sanitaire
mais j'ai en tête notamment l'arrêté
donc du 6 avril 2020 pour laquelle le
maire de sceaux philippe laurent
avait donc lui-même rendu obligatoire
c'est le port du masque dans sa commune
et donc j'en ai arrêté a été finalement
on lui a demandé
on lui a demandé de faire machine
arrière dans ses démarches
considérant que seule s'il y avait des
raisons impérieuses 10 à 17 ans locale
il a été en capacité de mettre en place
et a raté et donc là on a eu déjà une
décision qui limite quelque part le
pouvoir du maire et puis donné l'élément
peut-être offert agir sur des
préconisations qu'elle ne portait pas la
négation collectivités notamment qui
évoquait le fait que que le nous aurons
souhaité qu' on puisse autoriser les
prunes exercer un pouvoir réglementaire
d'adaptation locale dans lequel de la
protection la santé des administrés en
cas de danger grave ou imminent dans une
logique de subsidiarité et des
différenciations notamment lorsqu'on
considère que l'état n'est pas au rendez
vous et jouez à voir votre réaction
vis-à-vis tête cette idée portée par
notre délégation qui mon avis peut être
un sujet d'actualité dans les mois qui
viennent à la merci pour cette première
série de questions merci monsieur le
rapporteur donc le nombre de prises de
parole voilà c'est que mel patricia qui
donc aux apporteurs patrie séchage et je
te propose je vois là d'intervenir vous
pourrez peut-être répondre à ses
premières séries de questions et ensuite
nous poursuivrons donc ensuite si
laurent burgoa et philippe dallier pour
qui ce dans les starting blocks mais ils
le sont tout le temps à tanger en pris
[Musique]
aux propos de philippe à mouiller un
sujet qui est vaste et qui demande
beaucoup d'interventions pour pouvoir
justement nourrir ce rapport moi mes
questions à seront peut-être vous en
avez peut-être déjà répondu
à nombreux mais on demandera peut-être
de préciser un peu plus sur ces trois
questions que je vais vous proposer
depuis les années 90 la santé publique a
été marquée par un mouvement de thé de
territory il ya un tas lisation entendu
comme l'adaptation des politiques
publiques aux spécificités des
territoires
mais cette territorialisation a été
opérée non dans le cadre de
décentralisation et dans celui de
déconcentration cédé contre ans
concentration at elle produit des effets
escomptés selon vous et puis ne
doit-elle pas à présent s'accompagner
d'un mouvement de décentralisation ne
répond t-il pas une demande croissante
des citoyens pour une action de santé de
proximité beaucoup plus intense que ce
qu'on vit par expérience par certains
territoires
dans une volonté de spécifique de ce
simple petit castan pardon et
d'amélioration du service fourni des
sénat a proposé aussi d'élargir les
compétences du département en tant que
responsable des solidarités médico
social c'est surtout se confier au seul
département le pile le pilotage des et
panne ainsi que celui de la médecine
scolaire nous avons d'ailleurs interrogé
des élus sur cette évolution
dans le cadre de la consultation en
ligne qu'en pensez vous et puis enfin la
commission de l'aménagement des
territoires et du développement durable
a publié en janvier 2001 un rapport
d'information sur les déserts médicaux
alors il ya eu naturellement des
initiatives qui ont été développés dans
certains territoires comme l'aveyron où
le doom
que pensez vous des bonnes pratiques en
connaissances en connaissez vous
d'autres quel est le principal obstacle
auquel ces d'initiative se heurtent et
qu'il d'ordre financier ou juridique
quels sont les bons et sion pour
conduire de telles initiatives
merci merci beaucoup donc je je propose
que vous vous partagiez
les réponses si vous le souhaitez donc
ils vont intervenir en premier
monsieur renaudie professeur peut-être
oui je réponds volontiers peut-être aux
questions sur les pouvoirs de police du
maire
alors c'est un fait que ce qu'a révélé
la crise c'est au fond la manière dont
était envisagée l'articulation délicate
entre l'exercice par le maire de son
pouvoir de police administrative
générale a priori très vaste et
l'existence de très nombreuses polices
administratives spéciales venante
limiter l'exercice de ce pouvoir supposé
vaste et un auteur qui a dénombré plus
de 300 police administrative spéciale
existantes 300 police créé par le
législateur et dans des domaines
particuliers où il a estimé qu'il était
nécessaire de ne pas s'en remettre à la
généralité des pouvoirs de police mais
de spécifier des pouvoirs particuliers
ce qui fait que ces dernières années on
ne fait que constater qu'un certain
nombre d'arrêtés municipaux de police se
révèle illégaux car ils entrent dans le
champ de ces polices administratives
spéciales qui s'exerce à titre exclusif
pour la plupart d'entre elles c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé avec
l'arrêté du maire de sceaux celui ci
considérait qu au regard de la
topographie de sa commune de la
population de la configuration des
commerces il fallait en centre-ville
porter un masque
ce qui au fond aujourd'hui relève d'une
évidence mais il a eu raison trop tôt il
avait politiquement raison il avait
sanitairement raison mais il avait
juridiquement tort ils avaient
juridiquement tort au regard de la
manière dont aujourd'hui
le conseil d'état juge les conditions
dans lesquelles ces pouvoirs de police
peuvent s'articuler la décision du
conseil d'état qui a considéré comme
illégal s'est arrêtée elle est imparable
le juridiquement simplement là où elle
pose problème c'est que celle ci dit oui
peut-être que cela aurait pu être légale
à la condition que celui ci fasse la
démonstration de circonstances locales
très particulière et à la condition 17
décisions qu'ils ne remettent pas en
cohérence l'efficacité des mesures de
l'état mais là que veut ton est ce qu'on
veut faire des maires des préfets
sanitaires qu'est ce que c'est que cette
idée de remettre en cause la cohérence
des politiques de l'état
est ce la décentralisation que la france
a connu là moi cette décision me pose
problème non pas juridiquement en tant
que telle elle est parfaite mais du
point de vue de la philosophie la
décentralisation est ce qu'on veut
réduire les maires au statut de 2 ce qui
met en oeuvre la politique de l'état et
ne doivent jamais sortir de celle-ci et
ne faire que l'appliquer ça n'est pas ça
la décentralisation
donc dès lors que dans un cadre
décentralisée des élus locaux ont la
possibilité d'exercer des compétences et
doivent le faire librement dans le cadre
fixé par le législateur
l'autre sujet le pouvoir réglementaire
d'adaptation j'étais que c'est un sujet
qui essaiera là à la délégation comment
faire en sorte d'une part d'accélérer
l'édiction des textes d'application des
lois qui parfois sont un peu trop long
et puis de faire en sorte que ce soit
pas seulement le pouvoir exécutif qui
prennent ces textes d'application je
pense que la matière sanitaire pourrait
être un très beau terrain
d'expérimentation de ce pouvoir
d'adaptation des textes législatifs
c'est-à-dire essayer de confier aux
collectivités territoriales la
possibilité de prendre des
mesures réglementaires d'adaptation des
textes législatifs aux spécificités de
leur territoire et si on cherche des
domaines si tel est votre cas je pense
que la santé constitue un excellent
domaines où on pourrait expérimenter ce
pouvoir réglementaire qui pourrait être
confiée au aux collectivités
territoriales et professeurs et notre
réponse et en écho à patricia sillage
est aussi imposant prix juste un petit
mot sur l'âge je crois beaucoup à la
décentralisation en matière de santé
plus qu'à la déconcentration
je parlais de liberté tout à l'heure je
pense qu'il faut jouer c'est cette
capacité d'agir sur nos territoires et
on est capable d'innover encore une fois
mais en fait en sorte c'est pas un
problème pour moi financiers pour
répondre à la question c'est pas ça le
problème c'est ce sont tous les cars
quant à la fois juridiques législatifs
on rentre pas dans les bonnes cases donc
on peut pas faire voilà en fait c'est un
peu ça on n'a pas du tout de marges de
manoeuvre alors il ya plein de choses
qui existent on parlait tout à l'heure
des contrats locaux de santé
c'est c'est très bien mais on a en fait
assez peu de marge de manoeuvre encore
une fois pour réaliser très concrètement
des chaussures sur sur le terrain donc
on se heurte toujours aux fameuses
agences régionale 2
de santé qui sont là un petit peu comme
un avec avec un peu le bâton quoi en
disant non on pourra pas vous financez
parce que vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes
pas dans les normes alors je pense que
les maires font attention quand même on
n'est pas des va-t-en-guerre et on
essaie quand même d'avoir de réaliser
des choses de bon sens et par rapport
aux attentes de nos populations donc il
faut nous laisser encore une fois cette
marge de manoeuvre et nous laisser un
certain de pouvoir et ce que disait
frédéric tout à l'heure et tout à fait
juste c'est que les maires en fait il ya
énormément de sujets qui concernent la
santé cela de la petite enfance au grand
âge où les mères sont questionnés et
impliquer ses coprésidents et ensuite je
passerai parole alors berdoyes philippe
dallier sur les pouvoirs de police
j'ai finalement appris avec l'expérience
que souvent et il vaut mieux regarder la
pratique concrète la manière de
l'exercer
simplement la capacité à exercer un
pouvoir de police que ce que disent
strictement les textes je vais prendre
trois exemples le logement la santé
psychique et les bris était sur la voie
publique ces trois pouvoirs de police
que je suis régulièrement amenés à
exercer dans des conditions assez
différente alors sur le logement entre
parenthèses c'est un domaine où en en
réalité plusieurs sources de droit se
croisent pas que l'on relève au moins de
deux codes police de l'habitat et du
logement de la construction et du
logement police de la santé c'est assez
complexe
théoriquement quand on est dans les
degrés les plus graves
d'insalubrité d'un logement où on relève
dès lors d'une intervention de la rs en
réalité ce sont les maires qui font tout
le travail se sont noués chs ou les
associations mandataire qui se charge
des visites qui se charge de rédiger les
arrêter et c'est la rs intervient
pratiquement derrière uniquement pour
signer en bas de la feuille
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment piloter de manière très local
et nous aimerions parfois sur les
situations les plus dégradées justement
à avoir un peu plus d'être un peu plus
d'ingénierie de la rs mise à disposition
pour ne pas porter la charge de
situation si complexe sur la santé
psychique
autre cas autres situations là en
revanche on s'aperçoit que notre
intervention c'est souvent quand une
personne malade dès qu on pense alors
que ce soit dans son logement
voilà je vous donne des cas concrets il
est deux heures du matin on est samedi
des gens vous appelle ces situations
réelles mon voisin de palier mon voisin
est tout nu sur le palier ça fait 3
heures qu'ils hurlent et qui pousse des
meubles qu'est ce que je fais ou alors
c'est quelqu'un qui agressent les
passants dans la rue parce que là encore
face de décompensation d'une personne
malade souvent dans ces cas là c'est la
police nationale qui intervient quand on
est de nuit quand on est le week-end
c'est pas facile pour le maire de mettre
en oeuvre son son pouvoir de
d'hospitalisation d'office et de toute
façon derrière ça ne donne pas grand
chose parce que les personnes ressortent
au bout de trois jours dans la
psychiatrie publique est saturé
troisième cas d'école célébrités sur la
voie publique
ouh là ça pose un vrai problème parce
que si on veut pouvoir donner suite à
une interpellation il faut que l'ébriété
soit constatée pour un médecin
je vous mets au défi de trouver un
médecin pour constater une ébriété sur
la bo blick
sané
constater un décès le dimanche c'est
déjà compliqué une ébriété sur le public
vous allez vous envoyer la police aux
urgences elle attend quatre heures les
vacciner elle ne reviendra plus vous
demandez un max un médecin retraité ça
ne marche pas vous demander aux médecins
de la des pompiers ça ne marche pas au
médecin militaire j'en ai chez moi ça ne
fonctionne pas il ya un vrai sujet est
souvent vous voyez l'exécution la
capacité pratiques à mettre en oeuvre
des textes c'est là qu'on a shot
déconcentration et décentralisation
oui je reviendrai pas sur tout ce qui a
été dit enfin le système drs aujourd'hui
trouve sa limite et je crois que c'est
véronique besse qu'il a souligné nous
avons comme interlocuteur nous les
préfets qui sont des gens qui ont la
double qualité de savoir parler aux élus
locaux d'en reconnaître la compétence
d'une part et d'être polyvalent de
croiser les sujets de manière
transversale
ce qui est aussi très important et donc
le fait que qu'il n'y ait pas de
chapelle de l'état parce qu'il n'ya pas
que dans la santé qui en a qui
s'affranchisse de la tutelle ou au moins
du regard du préfet ce serait une bonne
chose
je reviendrai dans une autre question si
vous le souhaitez sur la manière dont on
peut travailler sur différents niveaux
de collectivités mais je ne vais pas
rentrer dans le détail sur les déserts
médicaux une chose est ce qu'on ne peut
pas un moment donné assumer je vais
beaucoup de précaution je suis pas
médecin mais de voir s'il n'y a pas
moyen de concentrer les médecins qui
sont une ressource rare et chère sur les
tâches pour le plus de plus value est
transféré quelques tâches aux infirmiers
aux pharmaciens dont on ne manque pas
dans nos territoires
on a même parfois des situations de trop
plein dans un territoire comme bassin
minier où le dos et déserts médicaux
s'installe on a tous les infirmiers
infirmières qu'on veut et ce sont des
personnes qui se déplacent à domicile
messieurs dans les chais le président je
crois que vous voulez rajouter
justin on pourrait poindre une question
qui a été posée sur la gouvernance des
ehpad et effectivement ce débat sur faut
ne faut-il pas simplifier la gouvernance
d pad je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
l'objectif de simplification
j'alerte simplement sur quel type de
simplification on a quand même vu à
l'occasion de la crise et ça a été
révélée jeudi au grand jour et tout le
monde l'a vu que les ehpad ou qui s'en
sont le mieux sorties étaient celles qui
étaient les établissements qui étaient
affiliés et qui étaient intégrés à des
des filières sanitaires et la proximité
avec l'hôpital
la proximité avec la filière sanitaire a
permis à la fois d'avoir des médecins
dans les établissements mais aussi de
pouvoir dire prendre en charge beaucoup
plus rapidement que dans d'autres cas
les résidents donc là mais l'enjeu de
médicalisation de ces établissements est
majeur il faut bien se poser la question
de savoir qui est si une
départementalisation la gouvernance
n'est pas de répondre est à cet enjeu de
médicalisation et la bonne à la question
de la bonne intégration dans les
filières hospitalière déconnecter les
ehpad du sanitaire me semble être un
pari qui au vu en plus de se faire entre
la crise et serait risqué merci beaucoup
donc je passe la parole à notre collègue
laurent burgoa puis philippe lasnier au
l'invitant chacun faire preuve de son
grand talent de concision puisqu'il ya
pléthore de questions il nous devons
absolument à 11h sur un autre sujet et
puis philippe merci mr présentons faire
au droit à votre demande légitime merci
à madame messieurs pour vos
interventions qui vont enrichir notre
réflexion moi j'aimerais vous interroger
par rapport au msp est la plupart
d'entre nous nous sortons d'une campagne
électorale où on a rencontré à dire les
maires de nos communes aux départements
et on voit fleurir c'est à dire de
projets de mes enceintes épuré spears
est quasiment dans toutes les coupures
dans tout l'est ou dans tous les
secteurs l'ours et des projets qui sont
assez ou c'est les projets qui vont être
lancés mais personnellement j'ai bien
peur que si on a connu quelques années
j'avais dire une guéguerre des
supérettes il faudrait pas que d'un
qu'on connaisse dans les années à venir
une guerre des msp surtout vu la pénurie
professionnelle c'est-à-dire connaît des
murs mais connaît plus de professionnels
de dac mc double question mesdames
messieurs c'est d'abord quelle est
l'unité territoriale pour vous optimal
pour réfléchir à cette implantation est
ce que c'est une commune est ce que
c'est une p c est ce que c'est un
quantum est ma deuxième question ne
pensez vous pas que dans des schémas
directeurs comme le scot la santé est
négligée et justement à travers les scot
se serait pas un moyen de d'implanter
plus intelligemment cms fait je crois
être assez rapide puisque ma question il
est exactement dans ce profil sur le
sujet de la santé comme surdotées yang
on est souvent coincé entre d'un côté le
besoin d'une coordination plus ou moins
grande et peut-être même d'un d'un
pilote dans l'avion ou d'un chef de file
et puis l'autre côté la demande de plus
de libertés des communes la finale a
évoqué et donc il ya quelque part aussi
une contradiction et c'est vrai qu'en
fonction de la nature du territoire est
là pour le coup le professeur je vais
reparler de de la métropole du grand
paris on peut pas aller réponses
pourront pas être les mêmes que de que
dans d'autres territoires
voilà chez nous on à l'ap-hp qui est
quand même je sais pas comment la
qualifier mais mastodonte qui doit se
coordonner avec les structures
hospitalières privé le département qui
s'occupe du médico-social les communes
qui essayent de s'occuper tout qui
effectivement on est en seine saint
denis c'est dramatique un problème de
démographie médicale et qui va encore
s'aggraver dans les cinq années qui
viennent avec les départs en retraite et
du coup on a le même phénomène qu'en
province où chaque commune essaie
d'attirer les médecins dans son cms dans
sa maison de santé etc
mais on n'y arrive pas et donc à mme
agrebi la solution elle ne peut
s'envisager quel cas une autre échelle à
une bonne échelle et qui ne peut pas
être la même en fonction des territoires
donc je voulais juste la drôlerie
interrogé sur ce qui doit être le petit
doit être le pilote au coordonnateur en
fait
merci beaucoup donc c'est la santé à
quelle échelle
oui les rails parce qu'il ya un sujet
aussi de la problématique de l'accès au
choix en ville que parfois on néglige en
se concentrant beaucoup sur des
questions qui serait celle de la
ruralité
je remercie président légèrement c'est
cette fois ci et je répondrai pas à
toutes les questions de manière à les
faire tourner la parole juste un chiffre
la france a perdu six mille médecins
généralistes ces dix dernières années on
ne va en perdre six mille les cinq
prochaines années
donc on peut créer autant de mépris
qu'on veut de toute façon la donnée
démographique
elle rate toujours raison sur les bonnes
volontés divers et variés
quelle est la bonne et la déflation du
msp il n'y en a pas à partir du moment
où il ya un projet médical c'est à dire
les médecins presse engagée on peut
construire des murs est ce qu'on
construit des murs en espérant que ça
l'est comme le miel attire et les
médecins gardent leurs murs et essaye
d'en faire autre chose il ya des
expériences qui existent puisque vous
parliez expérience et de la valorisation
d'expérience alors je peux d'autant plus
en parler que
elle a été menée dans ma vie mais on ya
pas que on s'est inspiré d'une autre
expérience qui a été fait à coulommiers
c'est clair qu'on a créé à fontainebleau
une maison de santé qui ajoute le label
d'universitaires maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires universitaire
pourquoi universitaire parce qu'on
travaille donc avec en l'occurrence la
l'université paris est créteil et la fac
de médecine et son département de
médecine générale qui est un peu
pionnier il ya quelques autres
universités mais moi j'encourage tout le
monde à les voir les doyens des facs de
médecine peut-être pour leur vendre ce
modèle là et leur expliquer en
labellisant ces maisons de santé
elles permettent à des médecins qui
s'installent dans ces maisons de santé
d'avoir géré le le statut de qu'on a
fait ça de 2,2 à deux intervenants en
université afin de de deux maîtres de
stage est de pouvoir accueillir des
internes et l'université s'engage à
nourrir ces maisons de santé au cid
internes en médecine générale de manière
aussi part à ce moment là effectivement
a ajouté une dimension de parrainage
d'apprentissage à un projet maison de
santé université à un projet de maison
de santé simples et on voit que la
hausse a été fait j'ai l'exemple de
coulommiers en seine-et-marne j'ai
l'exemple de fontainebleau
il ya d'autres exemples qui émergent et
une croix ou du côté de tours il ya des
choses qui se font aussi
et bien c'est un plus c'est pas la
réponse unique c'est pas le sait pas
mais disons que ça à 11 ans dans un
projet qui a une autre dimension pour
attirer la des jeunes médecins et qui
trouve aussi un intérêt à rentrer à
rentrer dans ce système des maisons de
santé universitaire voilà sur la
question du du bon escient c'est
frédéric a beaucoup réfléchi à ces
questions et il va pouvoir répondre
là aussi je pense que si on pouvait
rêver d'un système ou dans certains
territoires on pourrait dire c'est
peut-être l'échelon départemental
ailleurs ce serait peut-être le
groupement hospitalier territoire
ailleurs se serait lassé pts qui est en
train d'émerger
parce que il ya une force de médecin
libéral qui ai failli à une présence de
médecins libéraux qui est forte et qui a
envie de se structurer de porter cette
approche d'intérêt général je désire il
ya là aussi a pas de réponse unique on
rêve toujours de réponse uniforme
partout aux quatre coins de la france
mais elles peuvent être variées selon
la bonne volonté des uns des autres et
surtout je le redis selon l'état des
forces médicale dans chacun des danses
chacun des territoires aimef là dessus
en complément petit nom je passerai
rentrée sur les haies mais ce monsieur
le sénateur a parfaitement région et de
toute façon leur envol touladi msp ne se
fait pas sans médecin donc à un moment
donné s'il n'y a pas de bassin clients
de patients ça ne fonctionne pas sur qui
pilote
je voudrais insister sur le fait que le
haut niveau le plus local
il doit vraiment y avoir un rôle
d'ensemblier affirmé pour les mères et
les opci dans le cadre de contrats
locaux de santé est en dialogue avec
d'un côté l'hôpital de l'autre côté avec
le cpt est vrai que ça a été évoqué mais
c'est un excellent outil moi je ne peux
que me féliciter d'avoir une sur mon
territoire qui pilote de main de maître
la vaccination aujourd'hui c'est un
outil absolument remarquable en revanche
si on monte d'un échelon peut-être qu'on
peut esquisser une réflexion ou le
département serait davantage partenaires
de la cpam avec un travail sur la
médecine de ville la médecine scolaire
etc et de l'autre côté la région avec sa
fonction de construction de grands
schémas sa capacité à piloter de grands
investissements pour être en dialogue
avec la rs ou ce qui me succédera et le
chru et je pense qu'il ya une vraie
réflexion autour de cette capacité
région chru à distribuer les /
spécialité
dans les hôpitaux d'une région et donc à
distribuer les chefs de service et les
grands investissements ça c'est
davantage à mon avis une compétence de
la région
donc alors je passe la parole à rémy
pointereau le premier vice président
puis céline brulin puis anne catherine
loisier qui doit encore être en visio
voilà
chers collègues j'ai cette fonction
épouvantable de de timing maître du
temps oui oui merci madame le président
moi j'avais une question assez simple et
pragmatique qui concerne l'éventualité
d'une loi de décentralisation qu'on
appelle la loi cadets qui pourrait
éventuellement venir devant devant le
parlement
comment pouvons-nous faire mieux
fonctionner la rs qui est aujourd'hui
largement décrié dans son fonctionnement
par rapport aux collectivités les
régions départements
comment vous voyez-vous une
décentralisation on s'aperçoit
qu'aujourd'hui la rs c'est un petit peu
l'état dans l'état et qui passe souvent
au dessus des préfets et c'est là
d'ailleurs pour ça que ça fonctionne mal
parce qu'il n'y a pas de relation avec
les élus donc voilà comment on peut
faire en sorte que les collectivités
région département soit associer plus
largement au fonctionnement de la rs
merci ensuite je passe la parole
ai-je dit à céline puis à 1,4 et que y
ait un interlocuteur parmi vous qui
porte la réponse sachant encore une fois
que nos rapporteur compléteront les
investigations ils pourront porter les
questions de dix collègues qu'il
n'aurait pas pu être posée ce matin
merci beaucoup céline et anne-catherine
merci présidente j'embraye complètement
sur ce que vient de dire un autre
premier vice-président sur la rs sa
gouvernance on a bien entendu ce que
vous disiez sur le rôle attendu du
préfet qui a un rôle de coordinateur
peut-être plus intéressant que les
directions générales de la rs
aujourd'hui
mais quand même les ars elle avait pour
objectif il est raté à mon avis mais
c'était l'objectif de décloisonner le
travail des différents acteurs de santé
puisque c'était le regroupement de je
crois cette entité préexistantes
pourquoi à votre avis ça n'a pas
fonctionné parce que ça reste un sujet
qu'on fasse travailler ensemble les
différents acteurs dans la perspective
que vous avez développé les uns et les
autres et ensuite quelles peuvent être
les leviers des collectivités locales
pour travailler un genre de péréquation
et de réduction des inégalités sociales
et de santé par exemple
vous avez évoqué professeur le rôle des
régions elles ont un avis sur les
projets régionaux de santé
est-ce qu'il serait pas envisageable que
cet avis soit pas seulement consultatif
mais qu'on aille un petit peu plus loin
là dedans vous avez évoqué la formation
des professionnels de santé
c'est tout à fait vrai
mais ce sont les ars c'est pas non plus
illégitime et donc l'état qui décide des
quotas de professionnels à former enfin
voila on pourrait multiplier les
exemples mais comment les collectivités
ont un levier pour réduire ça et puis je
rejoins raterait rapidement les
questions de nos collègues présidents
c'est à dire qu'il ya quand même un
sujet moi je vais le dire avec mes mots
de concurrence entre territoires dans le
cadre de la pénurie qu'on connaît et
donc comment on fait pour que cette
concurrence
nan amplifie pas les déserts mais qu'au
contraire on essaie de les résorber
peuple si beaucoup si je passe la parole
à une catherine loisier je dois un droit
de réponse au professeur renaud dit anne
catherine loisier quitte en visio si tu
nous entends vous m'entendez vous
m'entendez
bonjour madame la présidente bonjour à
tous merci beaucoup d'intervenants droit
je voudrais juste rebondir sur les
éléments qui viennent d'être évoqués par
mes collègues et je voudrais avoir le
sentiment des intervenants sur
effectivement les capacités d'invention
et les initiatives de certaines
collectivités qui conduisent parfois et
je les observe de plus en plus dans mon
territoire en bourgogne à salarier des
médecins ce qui ce qui pose quand même
un certain nombre de questions en
matière aussi de surenchère de morsay
nation lire à des stratégies locales
donc comment dans ce contexte que pensez
vous de ces initiatives
comment selon vous pour nous préserver
une certaine quand même cohérence de
l'accès de l'égalité aux soins ça
repasse donc la question effectivement
de du niveau de décision des stratégies
dans les territoires merci merci
beaucoup je pense que c'est trop de
questions se ressemblent
assez pour certaines d'entre elles dont
professeur renaud dit je voulais
répondre à votre question monsieur le
sénateur concernant les maisons de santé
il me semble qu'aujourd'hui il n'est
possible pour une collectivité de
soutenir financièrement la création et
l'installation d'une maison de santé car
la condition de se situer dans un
territoire ayant été déterminée par la
rs comme nécessitant la création ce type
de tde d'établissement dans le cadre du
schéma régional d'organisation des soins
qui est établie par la rs ce qui est une
forme de contrôle ça veut dire qu'on
peut pas soutenir n'importe quelle
création de maisons de santé il faut se
situer dans ce cadre très déconcentré
pour le coup et on pourrait tout à fait
imaginer ce qui rejoint une autre
question posée on pourrait tout à fait
imaginer que les collectivités soient
beaucoup mieux associer à l'élaboration
du schéma régional d'organisation des
soins qui est un document de
planification stratégique fondamentale
établi par les ars peut-être de manière
trop isolé par celle ci s'agissant du
scot
le scot c'est un formidable outil qui
doit contenir un volet sanitaire
ça n'est pas le cas tout à fait
aujourd'hui mais au regard de la portée
juridique du scot
je pense que l'idée de renforcer celui
ci dans le domaine sanitaire c'est une
excellente idée
je crois savoir que la métropole du
grand paris est un train d'élaborer son
sens scott et il pourrait y avoir un
volet de santé
au regard de l'importance prise par ces
par ses enjeux
peut-être d'un mot les ars en effet le
constat est partagé selon lequel il faut
mieux associer les élus locaux à leur
fonctionnement est ce que ça passe par
la modification du conseil
d'administration de surveillance de
celle ci est ce que ça passe par une
coprésidence avec l'échelon régional ce
type de situation doit évidemment être
envisagée je crois néanmoins qu'au delà
de ces aspects organique
c'est bien l'élaboration des documents
qui sont réalisés par la rs tous ces
plans tous ces schémas qu'on a peut être
un peu négligé en se disant que au fond
c'était des normes de droit souple très
bureaucratique on en a vu l'importance
et il faut qu'au stade de l'élaboration
de ces documents de planification
sanitaire stratégique
les élus locaux soient représentées soit
à la table de rédaction de ce schéma
pour porter la voix des territoires pour
que ce qui figure dans de tel schéma qui
se révèle beaucoup plus important qu'on
ne pouvait l'imaginer
et bien que leur voix soit entendue à ce
stade et non pas quand il s'agit
d'appliquer ces schémas
deux ans après peut-être un mot de enfin
à nouveau trois répondent aux volets
initiative des territoires et évitement
d'une concurrence ce cycle quand on est
en situation pénurie vous l'avait bien
dit président valletoux qui vous
répondre ce point là j'aurais juste
rebondir sur la rsr rapidement sert à
terre il faut que le délégué
départemental de la rs et plus de
pouvoir il en a pas aujourd'hui donc il
ne peut rien dire
donc il faut que le pat le préfet soit
le patron et il faut aussi que tous les
niveaux des collectivités soient
présents
dans la gouvernance des ars pour avoir
un certain contrôle et pour mieux
comprendre ce qui est mis en place
si beaucoup on considère qu il a été
répondu où vous souhaitez parfait vous
êtes formidables et donc je vais
maintenant passer la parole à notre
collègue que donc la demande de parole
donc je vais essayer de faire les choses
en main fabien genêt messieurs le
gréaume bernard maigrot sonia de la
provôté voilà donc fabien michel gréaume
et bernard des crocs merci beaucoup
merci mme la présidente
c'est un témoignage une interrogation
une réflexion à témoigner ainsi lorsque
j'étais maire de digoin commune de 8000
habitants qui a vu le médecin quasiment
disparaître en quelques mois
et à l'époque la rs consommateurs et à
la rs et l'ordre des médecins qui a été
sollicité par les digoinais qui n'avait
plus de médecins plus de médecin
traitant et bien renvoyer ces patients
sur le maire est donc au-delà de la
répartition des compétences lorsqu'il y
as pénurie finalement on se retourne
naturellement vers vers le même donc ça
ne conduit une interrogation juridique
peut être apposé une professeure de
droit c'est dans l'actuelle répartition
des compétences
c'est l'état effectivement qu'il est
responsable de la politique de santé
lorsque cents
lorsque l'état est défaillant comment
finalement peut-on engager la
responsabilité de l'état au titre de
cette défaillance est ce que ça permet
aux acteurs locaux d'intervenir à ce
titre là et d'ailleurs par exemple le
conseil départemental de saône et loire
vient de lancer un second plan
départemental de santé qui salarient des
médecins généralistes qui va maintenant
commencer à ça près des médecins
spécialistes au motif que par exemple
dans un certain nombre des balles qui
était de sa responsabilité
il n'y avait plus de médecin traitant ou
il n'y avait plus de médecins
coordonnateurs est donc là aussi il y
avait en effet terminé en n'ayant
peut-être une réflexion un peu
provocatrice madame la présidente
mais étant élu depuis quelques années
maintenant ayant vécu sa situation de
pénurie sur le terrain
on a vu venir depuis 2010 nous sommes
aujourd'hui en 2021
je me demande si finalement face à cette
pénurie on ne se trompe pas de solution
et que au lieu de se demander quel sera
le meilleur échelon pour gérer cette
pénurie ne faudrait pas finalement
s'attaquer à la pénurie est considéré
qu'il faut désormais organisé un
concours de médecins généralistes par
exemple en fixant dès maintenant les
règles avec obligation d'installation
ce sont des propositions on a vu naître
dans les années autour de 2010 et on
nous disait à l'époque il ne fallait pas
aller dans cette direction parce que ça
mettrait trop longtemps pour former ces
professionnels
aujourd'hui nous sommes onze ans après
et finalement on en est toujours à se
demander comment gérer la pénurie
ça devient malheureusement semble-t-il
un biais très français merci chers
collègues michel merci madame la
présidente merci à tous je trouve cette
réunion très intéressante
merci monsieur chéreau pour avoir fait
la description réaliste est de mon
département et je suis totalement
d'accord sur le fait que laisse que la
santé est une compétence de l'état et ne
doit pas mettre en danger la santé de
ses concitoyens
en effet les indicateurs socio
démographiques des montrent la fragilité
sociale qui caractérise les hôtes france
avec un applicateur de mortalité le plus
important de l'ensemble du territoire
malgré les efforts des élus pour mettre
en place différentes actions notamment
je rappelle il ya des locations de
bureaux et des médecins qui sont payés
par les maires actuellement il ya des
arrêtés divers des actions sur la santé
il ya quand même une limite des
compétences justement pour ces élus et
faisons attention transfert qui ne leur
raconte pas les actions ne pas venir à
mon avis qu'en complément des réponses
apportées par l'état sur le manque de
professionnels de santé de structures
notamment comme chez nous dans le nord
avec une fuite vers la belgique pour les
ehpad pour les établissements pour les
personnes handicapées
manque de matériel qui donne des idées
délais d'attentes pour les examens a
normalement très long l'ensemble
occasionnant des surcoûts également avec
des dépassements d'honoraires et des et
très peu de prévention qui fait qu'
énormément de personnes aujourd'hui ne
se soignent plus voilà c'était juste une
observation merci pierre collègues à
l'arrière et cinq minutes alors je vais
vous proposer de relever un défi
je suis sûr que vous allez le relever je
vais proposer très rapidement parce
qu'encore une fois on a cinq minutes
pour de nouvelles questions et des
réponses mais je veux frustrer personne
dont bernard delcros et sonia de la
provôté s'ils pouvaient être d'une
extrême concision et ensuite je
proposerai une réponse parce que le
grand paris nous attend ce qui est un
autre sujet voilà donc bernard et sonia
en vous remerciant d'avancé de cette
concision en vous demandant de me
pardonner poursuit harcèlement sur
l'exigence de concision merci bernard
merci mais non merci à chacun des
intervenants pour ce qui est des chances
très intéressant je vais exécuter sur
avec la concision
j'ai deux questions je veux revenir sur
le propos de véronique besse que je
partage parfaitement sur l'idée qu'il
faut donner plus de prérogatives aux
locales pouvez vous madame baisse nous
préciser de manière plus précise quelles
seraient les mesures concrètes qui
aurait à prendre pour y parvenir
et deuxièmement je veux revenir sur la
difficulté dans certains territoires de
l'accès aux soins de produire autour on
sait que l'accès à un médecin
généraliste est souvent très compliqué
parfois impossible et contribue
d'ailleurs à saturer les urgences comme
ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure monsieur
clemenceau où nous avait dit c'est moins
6000 je crois un médecin généraliste et
on va continuer dans quelques années on
va continuer sur cette sur cette ligne
là pouvez vous nous en selon vous
quelles en sont les raisons
est ce que c'est le numerus clausus est
ce qu'il ya des
d'airé pour le métier de médecin
généraliste et en continuité pour
reprendre ce qu'a dit anne catherine
loisier est ce que les initiatives qui
sont prises en matière de salariat des
médecins généralistes
est ce que ça peut être une bonne une
bonne solution que l'évaluation est en
enfer souvent merci merci beaucoup au
sonhir le défi de la concision et pour
toi merci merci beaucoup madame la
présidente
donc je vais essayer de répondre au défi
est donc posé de questions la question
de la santé est une question extrêmement
complexe c'est un sujet systémique entre
la prévention à la prise en charge
programmés et non programmés les suites
de soins etc etc
il ya une complexité organisationnelle
et je voudrais connaître votre point de
vue là-dessus notamment nationale qui a
été mise complètement en lumière lors de
la crise que nous avons traversée
on n'a pas évoqué ce sujet la
multiplicité des intervenants nationaux
induit aussi une complexité dans la
façon dont des ordres et l'organisation
est transmise sur le terrain et donc ne
voyons pas là une première opportunité
pour rendre plus lisible et politique de
santé au plan national et notamment je
pense à un intervenant qui est le
financeur via des cotisations sociales
qui est la cpam la sécurité sociale et
pour laquelle on a besoin de savoir quel
est le rôle réel qu'elle joue en dehors
de celui d'assurance selon la prise en
charge sanitaire soit territoire et sur
cette complexité vous dire que la
question de la compétence santé quand
même un sujet complexe
est-ce que c'est peut être une
compétence partagée quelle est votre
point de vue ou une compétence répartie
avec une hiérarchie à champions en
fonction des gènes des échelons est ce
qu on répartit la compétence santé ce
qui paraît complexe mais pourquoi pas
finalement qui pourraient être utiles et
opérationnel est ce que vous voyez
l'idée de chef de file à qui pourrait se
dessiner sur certains secteurs de la
santé et qui en sera en charge vous avez
goûté la question de la planification et
de finalement peut-être questions
d'aménagement du territoire de l'accès à
la santé
est ce que vous imaginez des schémas qui
serait s'articulerait comme des poupées
russes de la région au département
lescott et puis les intercommunalités
derrière est-ce que c'est pas une
solution finalement où chaque acteur
l'état et les collectivités locales
ainsi que les intervenants extérieurs
parce qu'on a une multiplicité
d'intervenants extérieurs dans le
domaine de la santé qui pourraient
participer à construire d'aider des
politiques à chaque les sons qui serait
complémentaire opérationnelle et qui
permettrait de mieux gérer en
collégialité des moyens je vous remercie
merci beaucoup donc comme dans une salle
d'examen vous avez deux minutes
donc voilà donc je propose que nous
allions sur ce temps de réponse qui sera
aussi un temps de 2 de conclusion
président j'ai essayé d'être très
synthétique
tu penses que ya pas de fatalité à la
pénurie des médecins c'est aussi le
résultat d'une politique conduite de
politiques publiques ont été conduits
pendant des années et qui ont conduit à
ce set cette situation là on ment pas de
pharmaciens on manque pas d'infirmières
et c'est sans doute dans la manière dont
on a effectivement abordé et on organise
la médecine en france qu'il y à un sujet
mais qui est un sujet de fond on est un
des rares pays qui organise à partir
d'un financement je leur ai dit public
cohabitation d'acteurs sur lesquels
pèsent des droits et des devoirs très
différents ont tout à l'heure il était
pointé le roder le fonctionnement des
nrs n'oubliez pas que trs n'ont pas la
main sur l'ensemble des acteurs de santé
ils ont la masse sur les acteurs publics
pour ce qui est des acteurs libéraux il
fonctionne de manière je veux dire avec
leur propre mode de fonctionnement sont
toujours être partie prenante de
l'intérêt général et des préoccupations
d'intérêt général ce que je veux dire
c'est que le voilà je suis premier à
être parfois critique j'évite drs ne
faut pas trop les charger de tous les
maux à partir du moment où d'en devenir
consubstantiel d'un système est
organisée à ski ou de telle manière à ce
qu'il n'est pas tout n'est pas l'ailé
les réponses est en tout cas les
manettes pour agir surtout donc à la
question qui était posée tout à l'heure
effectivement ce que j'y fonce
se prendre ce manque de médecins comme
commune données sur lesquelles on peut
rien faire et écouter on a organisé la
pénurie de médecins a pendant des années
on s'aperçoit sans doute que c'était un
choix stratégique qui a été acquis qui
produit des effets contout convie tous
et qu'on subit tous on a encore une
bonne dizaine d'années à subir ses choix
stratégiques d'il ya quelques années
si on veut changer mais il suffit à ce
moment-là d'opérer le contraire et est
de rendre aussi peut-être de remettre la
question des droits des oubliées des
droits et des obligations chacun sur la
table il n'y a pas de question tabou
lorsqu'on parle de médecine le président
de la république a repris un chiffre de
quilles et qui a été démontré par
d'autres clubs
beaucoup d'études qui a sans doute 30%
des dépenses de santé en france qui sont
des dépenses inutiles
la régulation des dépenses de santé est
aussi un sujet important qui ramènera
aussi peut-être et s'interrogera sur le
rôle et la place de chaque acteur dans
le système est peut-être s'agissant de
la de la question sur l'engagement de la
responsabilité
je pense que tout est envisageable on
peut tout à fait envisager de considérer
que l'état pourrait avoir commis une
faute dans l'organisation des soins
simplement je suis pas certain que ce
soit sur ce dont peut l'imaginer
théoriquement je suis pas certain que ce
soit sur ce terrain qu'il convient de
s'engager on voit bien d'ailleurs que
les réactions des collectivités face à
la pénurie
ça n'est pas d'entamer des procédures
juridiques c'est de faire c'est de
salariés des médecins c'est de financer
des maisons de santé menées
[Musique]